how to do it better with GQ how to  button your suit jacket the right way  one know what you're working with count  your buttons if it's a single breasted  jacket it should either have two or  three buttons two being the cool guy  move three being the slightly more  old-fashioned version and if you've got  a double-breasted jacket well we'll get  to that in a minute for now congratulate  yourself on your advance style too if  you've got two buttons always button the  top never button the bottom three if  you've got three buttons sometimes  always never four if you're rocking a  double-breasted suit make sure you do it  right take the right button on your left  side and fit it into the secret  buttonhole on the inside of your right  lapel then same deal always the first  one never the bottom